[Music]
you both really came from musical
backgrounds you're a musician I know
that yeah I'm a drummer drummer and Kara
was from sleater-kinney and I'm just
curious well how did you start doing
comedy together that's that's the story
I don't know yeah how did we start it's
um we just kind of we didn't want to
play music together we just thought that
was like a normal route to go almost too
obvious yeah yeah so so we knew we
wanted to work together and we just had
this idea of just making these little
videos just short pieces that were kind
of comedy kind of just weird little
pieces you remember which one of the
first ones was like what's one of the
first things you started doing that you
thought okay we've got something here we
click boink yes boink yeah Fred was
doing an impersonation of Saddam Hussein
you shouldn't you should tell the story
yeah you would do an impression of
Saddam Hussein yeah I was at the time
you know and they remember they caught
Saddam Hussein caught him in that in
that like rat hole
yeah but then like he sort of cleaned up
a little bit and they put him in prison
and he had like that that like nice
jacket and a nice shirt he got skinnier
right and then to me he just seemed like
a kind of beard yeah like what so I you
seem like an aging rock star you know
like you know like an old punk or
something and I just thought like well
maybe I'll play him like I'm sort of
British old like your take on sit-up was
because all his photographs from the
trial where he was like this he was like
which to me looks British right I like a
British anger - Oi what you're looking
at
so so one of our first videos we just
thought like maybe in a basement in
Portland somewhere she's got a sort of
cable access show and she did this
character interviewing Saddam Hussein
who's Britt who's sort of a British
agent Crocker only one I talk about
guitar not about his dictatorship what
about it doesn't make sense it makes
perfect sense and it makes versus okay
what about this one of the most popular
sketches because what I really love
about what you're doing is so much of
the work is is coming from like the left
brain it's it's it's unique it's not
like you've seen it before you did this
thing where you you have a sketch that's
very popular I think it's one of your
most popular sketches called put a bird
on it I think we have a clip let's show
a clip first and then we'll discuss it
hi I'm Bryce shivers hi I'm Lisa
Eversman and we put Birds on things
today we're gonna go to a store and
Mississippi Avenue
nothing has birds on it but you know
we're gonna do we're gonna put ferns on
things press it up make it pretty Thank
You bird on putting a burn on this
teapot it's a bird
[ __ ] it's flying all over the beach
what a sad little tote bag I know I'll
put a bird on it did you see this bag
before I didn't know there's a bird
straight up got dust right in my eyes
just paint the bird or whatever does he
need to do and it don't blow on things
[Applause]
that's funny because that seemed to hit
a chord with people when putting a bird
on something how did that come about
well I had this observation you know
going into little boutiques and shops
that there would be these ordinary
objects you know mug or a lampshade or a
pillowcase but if you put a bird on it
it was elevated to art and so and and I
think it's really true I started
noticing it everywhere and so we decided
to play these artists that were putting
Birds on everything and it was just this
shorthand for something that became
ordinary to something that was elevated
now carries mystery you got one of the
Portland Trailblazers to put a bird on
his uniform yes he was a fan of the show
he saw the sketch I actually think we
have this
[Applause]
the other player is that gonna catch on
is everyone's start putting a bird on
the uniform yes and the whole NBA really
looking forward to that did you want to
put a bird here somewhere
I think we should yes Louie what do you
think of uh what about that moon move
put a bird on the moon yeah let's do
that
yeah take one I know you brought here
yeah this is a big big step big for us
we're gonna put a bird on our moon and
this is really gonna elevate our set to
art now this better not leave no is I
want this to stay on every night for the
next term you know ssin yeah
beautiful
[Applause]